what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking up with thor the god of
hammer storyline which is just concluded
so we're going to keep this going for
the next uh about six weeks or so um one
episode each week right we'll do this
what is today wednesday this was
supposed to go out yesterday on tuesday
but the miss marvel trailer dropped so
we ended up doing that instead so um
from tuesdays going forward is when
we'll have this coming out uh and it
starts off a little bit slow right
that's one of the things you guys
probably know just from like uh going
through and looking at like donnie
kate's stories they start off a little
bit slow in the first like issue or two
and then it just kind of blows up after
that and this one does exactly that it
goes in after about issue number two
what this does here and this is really
kind of cool it's a little bit of donnie
kate's kind of rewriting things in terms
of like the history of marvel not in a
major significant way but kind of in a
smaller way right one of the things he
talks about is the idea of elder gods
now elder gods have been depicted in
different ways over the course of marvel
comics i mean we know this just from our
coverage of thor over the years right
jason aaron presented us with the idea
of the elder gods insofar as like gore
the god butcher and the different elder
gods that existed across different
worlds gods of love and gods of peace
and gods of golden girls just all
different kinds of stuff
all different kinds of gods and in fact
donnie kate's actually lists them off
here right like the black winter the god
tempest right the king in black the
phoenix now the god temp this is one of
those things that's really interesting
here because the god tempest was
introduced to us as basically the source
of thor's hammer right like why the
hammer is able to choose who gets to
wield it because the god tempest was at
one point a cosmic entity it was a kind
of manifested as like this physical
storm that was raging across the cosmos
and ultimately odin and the storm fought
each other until such a point where odin
was able to take a piece of uru metal
and then trap the cosmic entity inside
that uru metal and then have a hammer
built out of it and that's really what
we're shown here right like the various
elder gods facing off against each other
right fighting that this led to worlds
smashing against each other and meteors
hitting earth and so on and so forth now
we could also look at this as a little
meta textual that the concept of like
elder gods fighting is sort of a uh
in-comic representation of just the
chaotic nature of the universe right
that like sometimes things just happen
almost sort of like how you would look
at uh at primitive stories now in terms
of like the explanation of the world
right like the bashango people of
central africa and like the great god
bomba and the creation of all things
right you know that kind of stuff so
again it can kind of go either way it is
marvel comics i would say donnie case is
coming at this from a more literal
perspective like there were gods in
space fighting each other and then like
when one of them hit the other one with
the world a piece of that world broke
off and then it crashed on earth and
killed the dinosaurs you know like it
seems pretty it seems it's comics
[Laughter]
so you could probably just roll with it
but regardless over the years and the
way this is done is that over the years
the hammer of thor has been a central
focal point of not really even just thor
himself right mjolnir has been
significant in so far as its creation
and the role it plays within asgard it's
as much a symbol as it is a weapon being
used by thor now in a lot of ways it's
synonymous with thor it was synonymous
with thor when jane foster was using it
and is synonymous with thor now that
odin's son is using it it kind of goes
hand in hand it's like captain america
and his shield and so it's one of those
things where really odin's son kind of
recounts all this right thor talks about
all this stuff and says that like in the
twilight of things right before jane
foster quote unquote died and ended up
coming back as valkyrie that what
happened is of course in that fight
between her and the man god probably one
of the best villains ever and the
entirety of the thor mythos just this
unstoppable force of anger that just
destroys everything in his path that the
man gog had basically been chained up by
the hammer of thor and then when the
hammer was thrown into the sun the man
gog was taken with it now one of the
things we talked about at the end of
that this is something i want to kind of
you know kind of offer an aside here the
sun is not enough to kill the man gog
not at all
you know someone like odin could survive
the destruction of a sun and odin is
terrified of the man gog right the man
gog is basically this unstoppable force
there's no real way to kill it there's
no real way to i mean sure if you're
like a person who can alter reality you
can just phase him out of existence but
even then it's questionable because
marvel's always presented the man gog as
just the physical embodiment of hatred
right the people that hated odin because
odin eradicated their race that is
hatred and anger given a physical form
so the man gog will always return just
kind of you know until the universe ends
it'll always find a way back but
regardless the hammer of course ended up
returning and that's how thor ended up
getting his hands on it there's no
indication that man god came with it so
maybe man gog is still stuck in the sun
we're not really sure but over the
course of the entirety of donnie kate's
run he's really been hitting on this
idea that for some reason or another
thor has is is able to lift his hammer
but seemingly so is everybody else right
now it's kind of turning things on its
head but also leaning in to the uh to
the the kind of pastiche that's been
going on recently right one of the big
uh big complaints that a lot of thor
fans have is that ever since the walt
simonson days and the days of vader ray
bill lifting uh lifting mjolnir that
word started out is like wow someone
else could lift the hammer of thor
that's crazy now it's business as usual
like hey are you telling a thor story
and you really want to get people just
to buy it have it on the cover that
someone else lifts his hammer and people
might buy it because you know it doesn't
really shock people anymore but it
stands a better chance and if they're
not
[Laughter]
then if nobody's lifting his hammer so
it's one of those things and i imagine
donnie cage the guy's know fool he's a
phenomenal writer it's cool to see him
lean into this right and almost kind of
offer this thing that it's like okay you
know what if it's really becoming this
sort of hallmark of the thor mythos that
like everybody can lift thor's hammer
then let's craft a story around it let's
make a story based on that right let's
answer this question that all these fans
have which is why is everybody able to
lift the hammer of thor and so what
odin's son does is he actually goes and
visits sif now remember heimdall's out
of the picture and with sif being the
sister of heimdall she's basically taken
his place so now she's the one that sees
everything and the question that he has
here is can you see my hammer and her
response is no i can't see where your
hammer is i can't see who has your
hammer i have no idea what's going on
here right all i know or at least all
you know is your hammer's gone and we
don't know where it is and so following
that this basically leads to us jumping
to what is in effect a kind of uh
gladiatorial ring now this is one of
those concepts that donnie case is
really experimenting on and really
experimenting with and in fact it looks
like the hand of one of the celestials
or at least the the head of the
celestial in nowhere but the way it's
described here is it said there is no
earthly translation for the arena before
you no common tongue that agrees on its
origin some claim it a remnant of a
long-lost civilization hunted down
dissected and scattered in the early
days of null's campaign of blood across
the stars some claim it to be sentient
somehow still alive its great fingers
moaning and curling in the empty
freezing wind of the abyss grasping in
the dark for a body that is long past
its reach crying out for years long dead
and death all can agree that it is a
place no man should ever know that to
see it to know it is to never sleep
again it's a place of testing the black
hand of god it's the pit right it's
where people go for whatever reason
where they basically end up getting
involved in this kind of gauntlet and
they fight each other now the funny
thing about this is that odin was
basically dropped off here now we don't
know if people can leave of their own
accord or if odin somebody just doesn't
have the power to do it on his own all
we know is that at the end of the
previous story arc that odin had
basically met with angela and the two of
them had left together and essentially
angela just left him here right and then
just took off and that was basically it
but thor arriving here on the scene is
really him meeting with odin as the
person who created the created milner
and saying i need your help to find this
hammer it's one of those funny things
though because seemingly everybody knows
that mjolnir is missing and that thor
doesn't have it right it's one of those
things because the hammer is so
significant in the cosmos and even thor
with the hammer is so significant it's
like captain america having no shield
you know it's like the silver surfer
having no surfboard people will notice
like they will realize that thor does
not have his hammer and because the two
go hand in hand together if for some
reason thor does not have his hammer
then it means it's either destroyed it's
somehow broken or just generally not
available to him and so that's how
everything has kind of been put together
as far as odin goes and all these
different guys and so the two of them
basically ended up traveling to
nadavalier now this is a really
important thing and the reason why this
happens is because thor asked the
question i do not know why you would
bring me to the dwarves i am not in need
of a weapon forced i need mjolnir
returning before it falls into ill hands
and the response of odin is the dwarves
can track their creations across the
stars if anybody can find your hammer it
would be them and it makes sense right
the dwarves are like the best smiths in
basically any of the realms essentially
in the universe if you're somebody out
there that wants to have a weapon made
and the dwarves of the davalier will
make it for you you will have a weapon
that is virtually unstoppable right that
is essentially indestructible especially
if it's magically enchanted uber metal
in the way that thor's hammer is the
issue is that when they get there the
elves have all been destroyed right like
literally the elves of the davalier have
all been killed here and it's kind of
nuts because initially the idea was like
okay like apparently there's war in this
forage and that's when thor is like no
this was no war right like look at the
val raven right there's no blood on
their talons still on their perches
right it's impossible whatever it was
that happened here happened without
anybody realizing what was going on they
were caught by surprise these are the
birds that see all the the ravens of
odin like they see everything and so
it's one of those situations that's
that's why you can't like sneak into
nadav lee right that's why like you know
black widow couldn't like dawn her
costume and say okay come on hawkeye
we're gonna sneak into the forge of the
davalier and we are going to uh we're
going to steal from the dwarves right
that's that's not how this works that's
not how any of this works
right they see everybody coming from a
mile away but whoever this was was able
to avoid that not only that they were
killed instantaneously before they ever
had time to react not only that once
they actually get into the forge itself
any dwarves that resided in this forge
were killed and the forge itself was
completely destroyed seemingly the
ability to create another version of
mjolnir is gone and it's one of those
things that just totally baffles both
odin and thor they're like okay it's
like the dwarves are all dead and the
forge has been shattered how could this
possibly be done and the response of
odin is like look at them like look at
the bodies of these dwarves look at how
they've basically been crushed you've
wielded it for eons now if anyone knows
it would be you and the response of thor
is yes like i see it whoever it was that
killed these guys used my hammer to do
it they killed the dwarves using myoner
now i will say this once the perpetrator
is revealed it's
crazy
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with thor yes we are the god of
hammer storyline and we finally get the
revelation of who the god of hammers is
and it's really really cool so here's
the thing uh in the first video we
basically talked about how thor's hammer
over the course of this run uh that
donnie cates has been writing that
essentially the enchantment like the
worthiness enchantment has basically
gone away so anybody can pick up the
hammer of thornel and essentially the
hammer of four had just gone missing and
nobody really knew where it went to but
what we also realized is that the hammer
of thor whoever was wielding it had
actually attacked the dwarves of the
davalier and basically obliterated them
now what we also find out as we open up
with the story is we end up finding out
that the hammer whoever's wielding it
has basically attacked the other realms
right the nine realms that are out here
the realm of muspelheim and like the
realms of jotenheim and all these places
have all been attacked by the hammer now
it doesn't mean that there are no
survivors there are people who survived
the experience perhaps because they
weren't there perhaps because they
suddenly just had the power to do so
we're not really given a definitive
answer here instead all we're really
told is that they had survived their
experience in facing off against the god
of hammers now again this is a pretty
significant thing because these are
realms that are full of some pretty
powerful people the rock trolls and like
angela and people like that i mean these
are formidable foes and so of course we
switch back over to thor who's basically
burying etre of the of the dwarves right
kind of the forge master the guy who was
the one that built mjolnir in the first
place and one of the funny things that
happens is that as thor is basically
paying homage to itri and he's on his
knees of course saying a bit of a prayer
and then offering a burial that falls in
line with the dwarven traditions that
he's met by odin who's just like that's
enough right like a king cannot rule
from his knees boy and thor in turn is
just like i've had enough of this and a
small little skirmish breaks out between
the two of them i wouldn't really call
it a true full-on fight i mean it is a
cool fight to see and it is cool to see
thor overpowering odin but it's really
one of those hits where it's just like
thor attacking odin knocking him to the
ground and then thor just lets loose and
it's just like this is all your fault
right like everything that's happened so
far is your fault donald blake going
insane during the prey story arc is
because you basically created a
personality out of nowhere bonded it to
me and then in turn i would jump back
and forth between the two but once i
returned to my normal self and i stayed
thor i had no idea this guy was
basically trapped in this other
dimensional realm with no conceivable
way to leave he was like this whole
hammer this whole enchantment the thing
that you've done here taking a cosmic
entity and binding it to mjolnir like it
was only a matter of time before
something like this happened everything
you touch odin every single thing you
touch no matter what it is it all comes
to an end everything that you touch
leads to ruin and death you are a
walking talking definition of bad luck
and the thing about this is that odin
acquiesces and odin's like yes like
believe me i am totally aware of this
right it's kind of been this guilt that
odin has been carrying around for quite
some time that as he was the all father
and when he was ruling over asgard he
was pretty hard on thor he was pretty
hard on his sons the idea was to
basically mold thor and also kind of
fall in line with like how he had always
sort of done things but at the end of
the day odin wasn't much of a father to
thor and so when you have this situation
where his son is just letting loose on
him basically spilling all these
realities to odin himself one of the
things that odin has to have to contend
with and has to come to terms with is
the fact that this really is all his
fault you cannot take a cosmic entity
bind it to a mortal artifact and believe
it'll stay that way forever somewhere
along the lines something will change
and whether it's because odin was hubris
and he never really thought he'd have to
deal with the consequences of it or if
he had just simply never considered the
possibility of it it all falls on the
shoulders of him but in the midst of
this argument between the two suddenly
they're whisked away to the realm of the
frost giants right to the realm of
jotunheim and that's when loki reveals
all these frost giants have been
destroyed by the god of hammers and
that's when he asked the question like
have you misplaced anything lately thor
and of course you know it's a rhetorical
question but as the three of them sit
down and as they meet the whole thing
here is that at some previous point in
time thor said let there be peace or let
there be thunder and when loki asked the
question like you're those are your
words correct right like you're you know
at your great coronation when you were
officially crowned all father of asgard
well where is your peace now right like
where where is your thunder where is
mjolnir where is this hammer what's
going on here and how could somebody
possibly get a hold of your weapon and
start laying waste to all the different
realms that exist out here and so that's
when he asks like who is he right who is
the god of hammers and the immediate
response of odin is like this is
nonsense right he says the god of
hammers is a myth an errant prophecy the
likes of which i have crushed and tossed
aside for thousands of years but in the
end loki makes a great counter argument
here he says like but aren't we living
myths us as as guardians we're myths
according to the mortal people right and
we essentially have been since like the
third celestial host when they told us
not to get involved in the affairs of
mortal men right so like ever since then
we have basically been mythical beings
but we are in effect gods among men and
ultimately where odin says like this is
different he says if i were such a god
and of course you know thor ends up
cutting him off but at the end of the
day loki makes his point here he says
listen to me both of you as we speak the
forces of the ten realms have taken up
arms against you they believe this
assault no matter the assailant to be as
guards doing to be your doing for so far
i've been able to keep them from letting
loose but i do not think i can hold them
for much longer so i don't claim to
understand what is happening between the
two of you but if i may get over it
because no matter what you claim to
believe this prophecy this myth is real
and loki goes as far as to say that like
he looked it up right he's like any
evidence out there anything that details
the prophecy of the the god of hammers
has basically been destroyed and it was
destroyed recently so whoever this
whoever's wielding this god or willie
mjolnir by whoever this god of hammers
is destroy the prophecy there's no real
information on this person all we know
is that there was a prophecy somewhere
along the line that somebody would come
along and they would basically like this
god of hammers would show up on the
scene right the god of hammers will rise
as it's described he will ignite the ten
realms and he will take the last king of
asgard and then there will be nothing
nothing but the distant sound of a forge
burning raging as the god of hammers
reshapes the world and that's when
odin's like okay so like we're talking
about another war of realms and that's
when loki is like no you misunderstand
the text is literal right it's not a
it's not a an interpretive thing right
it's not war it's not you know he will
ignite the ten realms a fight will ensue
between the two between all these
different groups we've done that dance
we know what a war of realms looks like
that's not what this text means they
will not go to war the ten realms will
burn the ten realms will be destroyed
and so ultimately odin goes to initially
chime in and basically speak to thor but
that's when thor's like the bifrost is
coming now here's the important thing to
understand and this is something that's
that's pretty intrinsic here i'm not 100
sure about this but i don't believe thor
knows the actual story of mjolnir we as
the reader do right we know that at one
point in time there was a cosmic entity
that manifested in the form of a cosmic
storm and that odin had faced off
against it and that odin had confined
that cosmic entity into a piece of uru
metal which in turn was forged into
mjolnir but i'm not entirely sure thor
knows the actual story of mjolnir right
how all that transpired and if he does
just by the look of odin and the way he
seems a little desperate in so far as
his desire to explain or at least to
tell this thing to thor it may be
something that we simply just don't know
but whatever the case is when the
bifrost emerges it's both throgg who's
basically the leader of thor's security
to a degree as well as sif right the the
sister of heimdall who is essentially
replaced heimdall and that's when like
they send thor to this particular
location and when he asks the question
like where are we right what realm is
this that's when thor sees the sign of
broxton oklahoma now this is one of
those times where when we covered the j
michael cerzinski run on thor we talked
about how the events of rocks in
oklahoma would never really go away they
would always be there right that's one
of those elements where initially it was
a little uncertain if it was going to be
important during strzinski's run but the
more it stuck around going into the
events of like siege on asgard and
things like that civil war the more you
realize that essentially broxton wasn't
going anywhere that brockton was going
to be a mainstay of thor's mythos for
quite some time for those of you guys
who don't know the significance of
broxton oklahoma the idea here is that
following the events of thor
disassembled colloquially known as thor
ragnarok when odin's son had basically
died and asgard was destroyed that when
he returned he ended up bringing asgard
back but when he did he basically took
the kingdom of asgard to brockton
oklahoma and there were some pretty
hilarious stories where the townspeople
just didn't like them being there and
they would like bicker with the
townspeople different things along those
lines but essentially that was the home
base of asgard for quite some time
eventually asgard ended up becoming
asgardia following the events of siege
when it was destroyed and rebuilt by
iron man and then it basically orbited
saturn for a little while but the
important thing here is broxton was kind
of like thor's second home to a degree
right it was the re it was a place where
asgard was essentially reborn it's it's
a significant place for him and so when
he gets there with broxton having been
destroyed seemingly whoever this god of
hammers is is going after everything
that is significant to thor odin's son
himself as opposed to just arbitrarily
attacking things but in his anger and in
his frustration thor summons the hammer
to himself believing that it would
basically bring the god of hammers along
with him the problem is that when the
hammer comes the hammer in turn just
like crashes directly into thor it
doesn't simply respond to his grasp
where he would just normally catch it
and so ultimately he's like what in the
hell is going on right like how is any
of this happening right and so
ultimately he starts to realize
somebody's there and he asked the
question who is that right like who is
that that's out there and that's when
this voice basically shows you know
appears to him and says thor you know my
name you've always known it and it says
i am the god of hammers in essence what
what it look what looks to be going on
here is the sentient storm the cosmic
entity that was confined within mjolnir
has basically broken free and taken
control of mjolnir itself so it is a
personal manifestation of the hammer the
rightful owner of mjolnir has finally
returned
man
man
man let me tell you something okay look
here's the thing man dude this story
like i'm learning this about donnie
kate's man donnie kate's dude this guy
is an amazing writer but his stories
never pick up until you get to issue
number three and man
okay dude the ending of the story is
crazy it's one of the best endings to a
thor authority not even any to a thor
story it's one of the best endings to a
thor comic ever all right so so okay
look here's the thing here's the thing
check this out so this story opens up
right and it says for over 4 billion
years earth's sun has burned the hearts
of countless evils to cinders and bones
and atoms but along the way the light
has been infected the well poisoned and
now a new evil grows in the furnace of
midgard slowly evolving growing stronger
every day waiting waiting for destiny to
arrive and it says of this ancient evil
spreading reaching out from the flames
of the untold destruction it will bring
upon the universe the total and complete
extinction it will herald that story is
not ready to be told yet
but there is only so much darkness one
can throw into a star before the star
turns black and what is forged in those
flames will carry that darkness right so
what this does is it basically picks
back up with the last conflict that we
had right the last battle that we had
we're literally thor's fighting his
hammer right remember for those of you
guys who are just joining us here in
case you just clicked on this for the
very first time that thor had basically
not really lost the ability to wield his
hammer it had turned into this thing
where everybody could wield the hammer
of thor whenever they wanted to now
that's not a new thing and depending on
what thor fans you're talking to some
people will just kind of be like really
but the way the donnie cates does this
is amazing right the kicker here is that
thor didn't know what was going on but
then suddenly the hammer was basically
going around the nine realms right
yottenheim and like muspelheim just all
these seven realms even to like broxton
oklahoma on earth where thor had
initially brought back asgard back
during the days of post-civil war and it
basically just started killing all these
different people and so we didn't know
why thor's hammer had an effect turned
evil and of course it basically turned
out that thor's hammer was now a
sentient being now the reason for that
is because the entire basis right the
power of thor's hammer is rooted in what
was called the mother storm basically at
some previous point in time odin had
captured a cosmic entity and placed it
inside the hammer replaced it in a piece
of uru metal that was forged into the
hammer so quite literally thor has been
channeling the power of a cosmic entity
whenever he was wielding his hammer and
this made perfect sense because it
answered the question how it is that
despite how capable thor is the hammer
always seemed to allow him to overcome
forces that were often times more
powerful than he was right like
juggernaut juggernaut's a perfect
example juggernaut is powered by an
elder god whose power dwarfs most all
magical beings out there with the
exception of maybe like catholic and
like zom and like that's it
that's really it right like the power of
sidorak is insane and is way beyond the
power of thor yet somehow he was always
able to hold his own against juggernaut
and even defeat him using the power the
power of millionaire except for the old
stories when juggernaut had a force
field and then mjolnir didn't work on
him somebody's definitely going to say
that so i'm going to beat you to the
punch but the thing about this is it's
it's a crazy thing because in this
moment obviously the god of hammers is
now the wielder of the hammer itself and
thor himself cannot overcome the power
of the god of hammers so in effect he
can't control his old hammer he is just
as subservient to his power as anybody
else so when the hammer's thrown at him
and it lands on top of him and he's
basically being pushed down into the mud
and faces the possibility of drowning
there's nothing he can do to stop it and
even with the god of hammers itself
there's nothing he can do to stop this
thing and so ultimately the question is
asked by thor because remember thor
doesn't know the story of the hammer he
doesn't know that odin basically locked
a cosmic entity inside this hammer he
doesn't know any of that all he knows is
just like the hammer was something that
he couldn't lift when he was younger
because of the enchantment of odin and
then eventually he was able to pick it
up because he was worthy and like that's
basically it what donnie cates does here
man he turns the entire thing on his
head and it's amazing right so thor has
a question right he says who are you
what kind of trick is this how are you
doing this and ultimately the hammer
says thor you wound me right you and i
have been together for so long well
except for that briefed alliance that i
had with jane foster which pissed off a
bunch of fans of the thor community
although i loved the jane foster story
and so the hammer says like you of all
people should know about sowing one's
wild oats right and the hammers is kind
of like call it a phase right i just
wanted to try something a little bit
different now where that almost seems
like a kind of offhanded remark the
hammer kind of poking fun at thor
there's actually a basis behind this
right which is so crazy because thor
asked the question like you don't know
anything about me and where thor gets
ready to like go on this rant right but
if you want to learn like let me up and
i will show you and so on and so forth
and and the the god of hammers like no
you know i'm done like i'm tired of
hearing your speeches and says that's
ultimately what this all comes down to
right speeches titles crowns thrones
parliaments and senate meetings and blah
blah blah i'm just afraid i've grown so
bored of it all here's the kicking of
this right here's a caveat to this if
you know when that that that story was
told to us when we were given this
revelation that odin had trapped a
cosmic entity inside the hammer and
that's the basis behind his power we had
to know something like this was coming
eventually right something like this
would have to take place a sentient
living thinking thing trapped inside of
a metal artifact trapped inside of a
weapon would at some point desire to
break free and that was one of the
things that was kind of established here
right it was sort of unofficially
explained over the course of like jason
aaron's run and like donnie kate's run
and even if you look if you take this
information and this really gives you
credence to how how hardcore and how
intensely donnie case was looking at
thor you look back at the old walt
simonson run from way back in the day
right from like 70s 80s and whatnot you
basically get this point where you're
just kind of like okay so the only
reason thor was ever able to wield this
hammer is because the hammer allowed it
the hammer allowed him to lift the
hammer that it had nothing to do with
odin's enchantment and so it's kind of
cool because thor of course summons the
lightning and then having his little
portion of the odin forest because
remember thor has the odin force in him
odin is currently like he's he's not the
all father anymore and so ultimately
thor ends up channeling the lightning
and creating like a lightning based
sword which is amazing well it's just
this it's just this ridiculously cool
thing but in the end like when he goes
to face this hammer like the hammer's
just kind of like do you never learn
right like have you never learned
anything thor the god of thunder you
should really know better no one can
outrun the lightning and so when thor
goes to lodge a punch against the the
god of hammers the god of hammers sticks
up the hammer and thor shatters his arm
like literally cannot break through his
own hammer and then at that point right
the god of hammers is like and there is
nothing mjolnir cannot break this it's
just one of the cruelest moments ever
and so that's when like the god of
hammers starts to spill these beans
right and when thor's totally shocked
the god of hammers is like i know more
than almost anyone i know how this must
feel i have been there thor odin's son
at your side in your hand every single
time you have beaten back another
gathering storm of death i have watched
for eons i know all of your deeds even
those that you've forgotten all of your
triumphs all of your secrets all of your
weaknesses and yes thor you can be
broken you simply just have to know how
and so at that point you get this really
amazing moment where like odin steps in
now here's the thing to understand this
is a big deal in years past this is
something odin almost never would have
done odin would have just been like this
is your responsibility thor right you're
the all father you do your thing and
that's kind of the crazy thing odin has
almost always been callous whenever it
came to his his involvement with thor
he's almost kind of been i mean he
treated him like a like a father treats
a son to a degree but there was always
this barrier there was always this thing
where odin was never the guy who would
read thor like a bedtime story or
anything like that right he wouldn't
really raise his son in the way that we
as people here would raise our sons
right when you are a father raising your
son there is a bond there that just can
never really be broken in a healthy
father-son relationship there is an
incredibly unique bond there when you're
little kids the roles are reversed right
the sons are closer to the mothers the
daughters are closer to the fathers but
as time progresses and the sons need to
learn how to become a man become a
healthy productive man that can give
back to the world they look to their
father to be that source of guidance and
that's where that bond forms and to a
degree that was the case between thor
and odin it was the case that thor would
often look to odin for some measure of
guidance but the kind of guidance auto
would provide would be like don't
disappoint me boy like it was that kind
of a thing but very a very harsh kind of
guidance right not very much a spiritual
god in that capacity right odin was
always incredibly hard on his son and so
to see him step in here like this save
his life and then say like let's end
this damn thing shall we that when the
hammer thinks that that odin is talking
to thor the response of odin is no i'm
not talking to you right i mean saving
my son's life obviously but i'm not
referencing you that what odin was doing
was working directly with seth now
remember sif is basically replaced
heimdall she's the one that controls the
bifrost and she's the one who sees
everything so quite literally what they
end up doing is basically teleporting uh
the god of hammers to a place beyond
creation now here's the thing and that's
what's so crazy about this this is an
entirely new concept created by donnie
cates this is something that we've never
seen before and we've seen different
depictions of places that go like far
beyond anything we've ever seen so like
a really good example of this there's
really two good examples that have been
used recently the first one is what's
called the realms beyond and that's
basically where heimdall was taken when
he essentially died but the realms
beyond is just the white hot room right
the white hot room is in effect the
afterlife right the realm of mistress
death that's why after that introduction
right the idea of like the realms beyond
and the establishing point of heimdall
going to the white hot room is basically
his afterlife that in effect mistress
death is actually more of an avatar of
the phoenix force than the other way
around right that the phoenix force is
like this omniversal kind of energy
source that exists out there that in
every universe has its own quote unquote
personal avatar but there are some
avatars that stand above all the others
in the sense they're referred to as
what's called the white phoenix of the
crown that's what jean grey was but the
fact that like the home base where jean
grey operates where she is at her full
totality in terms of being able to
manifest 100 of the phoenix force's
power is quite literally the afterlife
the realm of mistress death that a lot
of people hit at this as essentially
being death is more of a of an aspect of
the phoenix force instead of the other
way around this is actually compounded
by the old chris claremont stories when
jean grey with the phoenix force met the
realm of death it was actually explained
how it is the realm of death works and
its role with the white hot room but the
other part of this in marvel comics is
during aldewing's ultimates we were
introduced to something called the far
shore right the furthest point of life
and death where basically all life kind
of the edge of where it exists this
itself is far beyond that right if the
far shore we're talking about is in
effect the realm of like the one below
all or anything along those lines this
is way beyond that in fact that's what
we're told here that odin basically says
sif just sent that thing beyond the
farthest point of known existence and
endless abyss beyond the eyes of even
the most ancient abstract primordial
gods right it's beyond the cosmic
entities now it's kind of crazy the
question you kind of have to ask here is
like how did odin even know about this
place in the first place but this looks
like it's a place beyond the multiverse
now am i saying that it's beyond verse
no because i imagine somebody's gonna be
like the beyonders are coming back no i
mean there's nothing to indicate that's
the case
it'd be dope if it was but nonetheless
right this is just the furthest point of
existence right where basically you know
once you get past this point nothing
exists right everything ceases to be if
this is truly the case the only person
we know of who has ever been in this
particular location right the place
beyond this furthest point of existence
was thanos right literally if you guys
remember at the beginning of all new all
different marvel thanos basically
emerged from a realm of nothingness
right like he was literally trapped out
there where nothing existed because
remember thanos was banned from the
realm of mistress death he's immortal
and he cannot die and so because of that
like he couldn't go to the afterlife so
he was literally at least essentially it
seems like he was beyond even this point
right this furthest point of existence
so we have no idea what this realm is it
looks like sauron's there we have no
clue how this works but regardless
ultimately thor asked the question of
odin what is happening like what is
going on here this thing said that it
was mjolnir brought to life and that's
when odin finally reveals the truth to
thor and says that mjolnir has always
been alive son he says i trapped the
mother storm inside of it eons ago and
when the dwarves forged that cursed rock
into mjolnir they told me those who died
making it that their voices their souls
live on in the hammer itself i never
believed it was true but whatever it is
whatever has taken hold of that hammer
and ultimately you never really get an
explanation there instead what's
essentially happened here is the god of
storms has made its way back immediately
like it immediately gets right back here
again so that's the level of power that
we're talking about and even odin is
flabbergasted he's like no that's not
possible there's no way this thing could
just come back here but where it's
channeling itself directly at thor then
ultimately odin pushes his son out of
the way to save his life and odin is hit
by the hammer and basically crippled in
the process and that's when that's man
that's when you get this revelation
i'm sorry i'm so excited people but it
is dope oh my god it's so dope so this
hammer pops back up right and this
hammer says it hurts doesn't it right to
lose to be left alone and when the
question is asked by thor why why are
you doing this you get this amazing
exchange between the two this amazing
monologue that the hammer says you take
me for granted you always have but you
none of you ever understood me you
thought my enchantment meant you must be
a worthy warrior to be noble or true of
heart but ask yourself thor does any of
that describe you are you a noble person
are you true of heart are you an
inherent good guy no thor you're a dick
you kill people all the time any any all
these enemies out there you kill them on
a regular basis and and like as soon as
i read that i was like damn son she's
right okay this is a really good example
during the secret empire event one of
the things that happened is people were
mad because stephen right evil captain
america could lift the hammer of thor
and one of the arguments was like he's a
villain he's killing people all that
kind of stuff and then like in hindsight
looking at that it's like is thor really
any different thor like literally just
goes on these crusades killing people
that he has personally deemed as enemies
like literally thor is like i am a good
guy i know that because i have decided
that like that was basically thor like
in his early days before he joined the
avengers like he just relished in
conflict in war and death and
destruction and so the hammer says no no
i am a hammer to be worthy of me is to
break to smash to destroy thor because
that's what hammers do and you with your
throne and your crown and your speeches
well this isn't the first time i've
grown tired of you isn't it and that's
when thor's just kind of like jane
foster right that's when he realizes why
it is the hammer switched to jane and
the hammer says yes jane threw me into
the sun and you left me broken you left
me to burn but you see i was not alone
in the sun you guys remember jason those
of you guys remember jason aaron's run
you know what's coming son you know it's
coming son so this is like i wasn't
alone in the sun there was something
else there something powerful and we
burned together and then we were remade
as one its spirit became entangled with
mine its soul inside of me thor picks up
like that and he's like oh dear god no
he's like no
the worst possible situation
absolutely okay so it says this is and i
awoke with a voice with the rage of a
billion billion beings with the rage
with the rage son of the man god with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an
man i'm sorry i'm so excited people
man man okay y'all it's my birthday
today it is my birthday i am officially
38 years old
i'm an old man so we're picking back up
with thor and uh
son okay man okay the last issue was
legit right the last issue was amazing
this one's even better okay so here's
the thing so thor ever the man's man
after getting his arm destroyed by the
god of hammers which is basically merged
with with like man gog right just the
sentience of rage right just rage
unbridled just wildly powerful this
indestructible being that cannot be
killed uh essentially thor just like
sets his arm right and he's like okay
like let's let's see what's going on
thor has this statement that he makes
and he's like so that's it right like
you've been possessed by the man gog
well you've come to the right place
mjolnir
i can help you let me beat that demon
out of you right i absolutely love i i
love that moment right like i love that
so at that point it's one of those
things where the hammer kind of makes
this argument and saying like not
possessed right joined intertwined now
here's the thing to understand this is
the important thing to understand one
does not simply join with man gog right
it doesn't work that way man gog is
literally just rage and cardiff those of
you guys who don't know who man gog is
man gog is just this horrifying thing
right it's like the only thing that odin
is afraid of and odin's fought galactus
rightly you thought galactus do a stanza
well technically head by the galactus
and then like fractured as hell but like
you guys get the point right i mean he's
fought some super powerful people the
idea behind mangog is that somewhere
along the line there was a race that
odin had led to the destruction of he
had basically conquered and destroyed
them and in doing so they channeled all
their rage and anger into a singular
entity which became the man god whenever
this guy shows up all hell breaks loose
like as guardians will just die there's
no way to truly kill this guy and so a
fight ultimately starts to break out
between the two now in this moment right
in this fight you actually have this
moment because of the fact that odin is
largely incapacitated what you get is
basically beta ray bill stepping up
right now here's the thing this we kind
of skipped over this little seven
because it's actually how it opens but
technically what happens is like beta
ray bill basically grabs all these
different superheroes on earth and from
across the realms and it's like if you
wish to leave now is the time he's like
in this battle that we're going to face
one way or another it's going to end in
blood some of us will not survive this
just so you know so if you are soft
if you are weak at the knees if you are
incapable of handling the kind of threat
that we're going to be facing off
against here then head on home watch
your favorite shows eat some more meals
and nobody's really well everybody's
going to think less of you but like you
know milk stops go do your thing
[Laughter]
goby milk stops and in the end none of
them really seem to go away now one of
the things to know this is not like an
entire like the entire coming together
of the whole superhero community i mean
it's some of them right like it's it's
the ones that material could get a hold
of but you still got some heavy hitters
here right you're talking about doctor
strange you're talking about wolverine
which i don't even know what he's going
to do but you got like like ben graham
which i don't know what he'll do either
but like most of these guys are here and
it's kind of cool but it's one of those
things where in the end thor tells them
like no right do not come here and when
they initially believe that they can
somehow basically engage in this fight
it doesn't work because what they're
doing is they're fighting what is in
effect one part cosmic entity and one
part just energy source it's not easily
defeated the only one here that could
truly pull off a feat and having a
chance in beating this guy would
basically be like doctor strange or iron
man and with iron man it's only because
of his repulsor beams but even then is
very limited in scale instead where dr
strange steps in and doctor strange
tries to defeat this thing ultimately it
doesn't work and so what ends up
happening is thor does the only thing he
can do right thor prays and this is
crazy right because he he like literally
reaches out and says mother like i need
you please please hear me grant me your
gifts give me your power so that i may
protect those in need so that i may
serve my father and then boom the power
comes and that's when he literally
unleashes this colossal maelstrom that
no one can get through now here's a cool
thing about this right because i imagine
a lot of you guys are kind of like okay
what's going on here so that's literally
what iron man says iron man's like okay
anybody know what the hell is going on
[Laughter]
because literally this giant tornado
came out of nowhere and that's when reed
is just sort of like okay so like it
appears to be a kind of well for lack of
a better better term energy tornado
right but it's not behaving in any
natural way that has ever been recorded
he's like for one all of us should be
dead standing next to an energy source
this strong and so the the conclusion
that reed richards draws is that it
seems to be something that the hammer's
doing that's when freya chimes in and
says no this was not caused by by the
hammer this was caused by thor and in
the end the response of of reed is like
okay but that doesn't really make any
sense right because like without his
hammer how could thor whip up a
maelstrom like this and that's when she
says no no right he is more than a
hammer he's a child of midgard i raised
him but his birth mother is gaia herself
mjolnir may rebel against thor but the
earth bends its knee now here's a very
very important distinction here because
what's been going on in recent months is
there's been a lot of back and forth in
marvel comics and really to the dismay
of a lot of thor fans to be honest with
you guys i mean for the people who are
like old-school thor fans they don't
want to see the mythos change they're
kind of pissed off for people who are
like new to thor and they don't really
know one way or the other it's probably
just passing curiosity but for years and
years and years when i say years i mean
like decades in marvel comics thor is
the was the biological child of odin and
gaia right like mother earth basically
so at the end of the day what ended up
happening is during jason aaron's run
what he did is he shifted things up and
he said that quote unquote the phoenix
force is the mother of thor the issue
with that is we didn't really know what
form that took like we had no real idea
what was going on so jason aaron's kind
of been doing his own thing but marvel
as a whole largely seems to be sticking
with the idea that thor is the child of
gaia right like that's his biological
mom and that's why he has the the potent
ability to control the elements of the
world and so what's really really cool
is that in the end there's a kind of you
know maybe a bit of a discussion that
happens between the two and initially it
seems a little lackluster but initially
it's just kind of like okay i mean this
could certainly be better but what's
really cool about this is in fact dottie
cates ties this into everything right
thor asked the question why why did you
do this why have you killed so many in
my name i don't understand and the
hammer says i used to bleed across the
stars thor i was beautiful the mother
storm shapeless incandescent lights
broke and scattered across my body i was
alive i was feared luminous and dreadful
and free your father trapped me eons ago
he used me enchanted me treated me like
i was a toy it took so long but the man
gog opened my eyes he's another of your
father's sense and she says you know he
taught me that the gods deserve a
reckoning for the games that they play
and so we began to unravel them all of
odin's little toys we began to tweak
them to set them free and that's when
you learned like the midgard serpent
didn't just randomly appear in the realm
of donald blake during the praise
storyline you guys remember that we
covered that video when donald blake
escaped and went crazy because he had
basically just lost his mind been
trapped inside his own little dimension
that's where he was basically sent to
whenever uh thor took over whenever like
the thor personality came back and quote
unquote donald blake went away thor
never really seemed to fully know what
was going on and the curse was that
donald blake was locked inside this town
but ultimately when the midgard serpent
came in a way in is a way out and so
with the entire little world being
destroyed and donald blake already going
crazy it offered him a way out and
that's what the hammer was shooting for
they're the ones who set them free
they're the ones that killed the midgard
serpent and sent it there right they're
the ones that did all of that and so
quite literally the hammer says we let
the devil out and the response of thor
is no right you have not met any devil's
mjolnir but you will now this is a huge
moment here right this is something that
i want to specify what's what's
happening here is a huge moment because
what ends up going on is that for a
moment thor is able to encase the power
of the hammer and when that does he
meets with his father now here's the
thing donnie kate's handling of odin in
this story is phenomenal and the reason
why is because like we talked about in
the last video odin's pretty he's never
really been expanded on too much in
terms of like his personality his
mannerisms different things like that
there's been a boatload of stories where
like odin's old sins have come back to
haunt him but the relation between like
odin and thor has always been that odin
was hard on his son and it was one of
those things where she's like you can be
better than what you are and he was just
he was just hard on him like all the
time like never cutting him any slack
and so in the end there's this
conversation that takes place which is
absolutely incredible here what happens
is that thor says we have to get you
help i can carry you to wherever it is
you have to go and the responsibility is
no i'm not going anywhere you need to
listen to me this hammer is right all of
this was all my fault these are all
things that i have made and they have
all come undone and what he does is he
reaches out to his son and he says all
of them except for you you thor you are
the greatest thing i have ever made and
this is i mean this is this like brings
thor to tears because his father's never
said that his father like odin has never
said that to thor like odin has never
really sat his son down and said just so
you know and like a really really
touching and sentimental moment just so
you know you're my greatest creation
right like that moment in like i was at
iron man 2 when like uh when tony stark
gets that message from his father you
know he's like you are and will forever
be my greatest creation thor never got
that in the comics he's never ever ever
ever really had that even when odin like
died fighting certain he never really
got that what he's getting here is in
reality the one thing he always wanted a
father and that's what odin is being for
like he is being a father like telling
him i will always love you and you have
always been my greatest creation and
odin says but i have been selfish he
says when you took the throne i had so
much more i wanted to do i wanted your
mother to see me again i wanted to be
strong and so i held back now that's
also an important distinction here
because the there was a lot of trouble
in paradise when it came to the
relationship between odin and freya that
in the end they were going their
separate ways right they were just going
to their their own directions and it was
one of those things where it kind of
made sense right the relationship
between odin and freya was something
that had just never truly been explored
in a deep degree in marvel comics it was
just kind of like they're together you
know king and queen of asgard and they
do some stuff and we are here now so
let's continue on with the story and
that's basically all it was and you
never really saw a lot of development
there one of the great things about
what's happened with odin about the
writing of odin over time and really
really starting with jason aaron's run
to a degree is that a lot of the stories
that focus so much on the human side of
odin for example when freya was stabbed
by loki during the war of realms and it
looked like freya was gonna die odin
stayed shut up in his throne room with
freya while he stayed there with her he
would never leave he would never leave
he would never go anywhere he wouldn't
take any visitors he wouldn't hear
anybody all he wanted was to be by his
wife's side and that's completely
understandable right because one of the
best things about this is that you know
for the hard shell that odin puts out in
the end once you look at like a lot of
the modern stories that are going on
with this character he's a lot gentler
than you would think he is now some
people will take that and say see that's
that's ridiculous odin's supposed to be
a hard ass is he really though like is
it is it is it really because i would
say what you're seeing now in donnie
cates is run as a guy who's been reading
comics for 30 years almost this is some
of the best writing on odin that i think
i've ever seen in the history of marvel
comics it's amazing or at least in my
time reading marvel comics it's
absolutely phenomenal but what he says
here is he says with everything that he
was wanting to do that with him holding
back when thor asked what are you saying
i don't understand the response of odin
is he says the odin force it cannot be
given in full until i am gone and odin
sacrifices his life and pours the
entirety of the odin force into thor now
this is an important thing to understand
here because there's only ever been one
time before when thor had the totality
of the odin force you guys know what i'm
talking about ladies and gentlemen you
know what i'm talking about y'all know
what i'm talking about if you've been
reading comics for any measure of time
you know exactly what i'm talking about
there's only been one time when when
thor's had the full totality of the odin
force right thor begs his father no do
not do this odin kills himself
annihilates his own existence and in
doing so takes the entirety of the odin
force and pours it all directly into
thor and so what's crazy is freya
actually senses what's happening she's
just like wait a minute what like is
odin dead and then you get this voice
out of nowhere and literally it's just
mjolnir right like thor just screams and
he's like you have killed in my name
brought misery to my home you have taken
my father and the hammer's just like
what in the hell and thor's like you
wanted to fight you got it come on big
boy let's dance
what's going on guys this is rob and
honestly i was supposed to wait until
next week to cover this but i'm not
going to i'm going to go ahead and cover
it now
because the god of hammers is just so
good what it looks like is there will be
like an epilogue to this so we'll cover
that epilogue once it's released
assuming it hasn't come out already i'll
have to double check and make sure uh
but picking up off the last video that
we did this is now thor with the full
totality of the odin force now here's
one thing that i want to specify here
and it's one of the things that donnie
cage has established here that the odin
force in its full totality its
completion cannot be fully handed over
to thor until odin has completely passed
on which means that there's only ever
been one time when thor had this level
of the odin force and that was when he
was ruined king thor that seems to be
the only time or at least there were a
couple things that added as a caveat to
that like powered by the nornstones and
so on and so forth but thor's
ridiculously overpowered here right it's
the most powerful version of thor that
we've seen with the exception of rune
king thor and presumably when he had the
power cosmic although we're not entirely
sure i don't think marvel's ever really
scaled the power cosmic versus the odin
force although i think it just stands to
reason through common sense at least for
those of us who have read comics that
the the odin force is not nearly as
powerful as the the power cosmic right
so you just kind of roll with that and
accept it but ultimately what ends up
happening is that in this conflict thor
actually ends up summoning hofan from
sith right hopeful basically being the
sword of heimdall that has now been
passed to sif following heimdall's death
and so the cool thing about this is that
when with him having that and using the
odin force one of the things that sif
says is you can't be reckless with this
power this power you have you can't just
use it willy-nilly this is not like
years gone by where you basically have
you know you can just face off against a
threat seemingly forever if you exhaust
too much of the odin force you'll fall
into the odin's sleep even if that
happens in the middle of a battle right
you could literally be fighting this
person and then just pass out and if
that happens they'll destroy you because
i can't keep you protected from this
storm it's just way too powerful but the
response of thor is i don't care give me
your sword and in turn the sword is
handed to thor who uses it to open the
bifrost and then teleport uh the the
really the sentience of the hammer the
storm directly to the forge where uh
where mjolnir was made and it's cool
because he snatches the hammer back from
it and it's just like do you recognize
this place like do you know this place
and initially the the the the storm is
kind of like not right off the bat and
thor's like this is a forge right this
is where you were born mjolnir and this
is where you will be destroyed this is
where you will be ended and so what ends
up happening here and this is a crazy
thing thor quite literally reignites the
forge and in doing so right it's like
the heat of a billion suns which is
enough to seemingly overpower the uh the
storm itself and then in doing so with
when it initially tries to take the
hammer back and use it again thor takes
the hammer back a second time and at
that point thor starts smashing the
hammer on on the forge now this is
absolutely insane because one of the
things to keep in mind when it comes to
the thor mythos you know a situation
where he quite readily starts destroying
his own hammer that's not something that
you would normally see and in fact thor
prizes the hammer above all else and his
use of the hammer is only a relatively
recent thing in the lifespan of thor for
those of you guys who never read jason
aaron's run one of the things that was
established in thor god of thunder is
that for years he was never able to lift
mjolnir the enchantment was put on the
hammer and the hammer was basically left
there by odin so that when thor was
ready he could pick it up and he could
wield it but for quite some time in his
life he wasn't really able to he was
never really able to wield a hammer the
only thing that he really had at his
disposal was yarn bjorn which is why if
you go when you read uh rick remembers
uncanny avengers there's a point where
he fights apocalypse in the past but he
can't use his own hammer he ends up
having to use a battle axe that's
magically enchanted to destroy celestial
armor and that's how one yarn burn
becomes as powerful as it is and two how
it is that he's able to overpower
apocalypse and so this hammer is a core
part of thor's life right it's as much a
part of his own body as his beating
heart and so destroying it is not
something that he readily does but in
going through and ripping this hammer
apart obliterating this hammer what it
seems to do is destroy the essence of
the storm now this is where things get a
little murky and this is something that
may very well be addressed in the in the
epilogue if it's ever addressed by
donnie cates at all although knowing
donnie kate's there's a couple
conclusions we can draw here the first
is that the storm existed outside of the
hammer right that it was literally
encased inside the hammer at some point
in time by odin and so destroying the
hammer doesn't seem like it would be
enough to destroy the storm the storm
would just dissipate and go back out
into the universe and then continue its
quest of death and destruction the other
part other conclusion that we can draw
from this is the fact that because the
the storm had been imbued to the hammer
for so long that it is part and parcel
to the hammer so if the hammer is
destroyed the storm dies with it it
could also be that simply just the power
of the sun just melts this thing and
that's kind of been a a cornerstone of
the thor mythos really since jason
aaron's run that the power of the sun is
so extreme that if someone is encased in
it they could basically be obliterated
by it i mean quite literally that's what
happened with man god that man god's
physical form was destroyed in the sun
and that its spiritual essence lived on
hence the reason why it bonded itself to
the hammer right why it bonded itself to
the storm but it's kind of a crazy thing
because even when you look at that like
a star is not really powerful enough to
destroy a being of sufficient power
right it's like throwing a beach ball of
thanos this really wouldn't make any
sense right and so it really can kind of
go either way which is why i say i don't
think we've heard the last of this i
don't i don't think we've seen the last
of this storm or any of this stuff but
what we do end up getting is that in the
aftermath of this because it required
the totality of the odin force to
destroy this hammer thor ultimately
passes out and then when he wakes up
four months have passed now again that's
the nature of the odin sleep that the
odom sleep kind of changes depending on
who's writing the story so there are
times when the odin's sleep has lasted
almost a year and there are times when
it's lasted like a month but in effect
all this is is just thor recharging
that's really all it is it's him
recharging the power of the odin force
because remember it's part and parcel to
him now thor is in the in possession of
the totality of the odin force that
seems to be the case and so as he begins
to wake up one of the things that he
says is that he feels like he heard the
voice of odin while he was in the odin's
sleep and then ultimately ends up you
know waking up and realizing that
angela's there and freya is there and
loki's there right angela being the
sister of thor you know from uh from the
realm of heaven but nonetheless it's
kind of a funny thing because what he's
told there is that in the time that he's
been gone a funeral has not been held
for odin and the reason why is because
thor should be the one to lead that
funeral so it's very ceremonial and
honestly it's very very appropriate but
at the end of the day angela's like you
know we'll hold a ceremony right but
there's there's no rush there was
nothing to bury right there's no body or
anything like that like odin is totally
gone right his essence has been
dispersed you are now in possession of
the odin force and that's basically it
and so in turn they're all you know you
have like loki and you have freya and
it's kind of like i mean look you know
you need to rest you need to to let your
energies recover and the response of
angela is he doesn't need any of that
like we all know what he needs where he
does not need to rest he doesn't need
any grape juice right he doesn't need
prune juice he doesn't need the golden
girls what thor needs is exactly what
we've done for him and so ultimately she
says get dressed meet me in the armory
and so what ends up happening is once
thor gets there is this really really
amazing moment when thor gets to the
armory he finds the hammer has been
restored and it was restored by the
angels of heaven now i want to offer a
bit of an explanation here a lot of you
guys who have been reading thor for a
long time you guys know or at least
already know this but for the people who
are new here i want to make sense of
like the realm of heaven and angela and
all that stuff right so the idea here is
that the character of angela was
originally part of the spawn mythos out
in image comics for the longest time but
what ended up happening is through a
series of rights ownerships and all
kinds of stuff the character of angela
ended up coming over to marvel because
the guy who created her came over to
marvel and so that basically meant that
all the things he created came with him
because when it comes to like
independent creators their own creations
are their own product they belong
directly to them and not anybody else
which is one of the reasons why you see
a lot of major comic book creators write
indie comics because they maintain total
ownership but the way that marvel played
this out is they said that angela was
actually from a realm called heaven and
it was the tenth realm instead of it
being the nine realms but due to a
conflict that had been held at a
previous point in time and what was
basically a kind of armistice so to
speak not really even a treaty just
essentially a ceasefire that the tenth
realm was cut off from the nine realms
and it was allowed to just kind of live
out there and do its own thing but all
that was covered in original sin and so
when this revelation came to pass you
ended up learning there was this great
big huge realm out there right and it
was called heaven and it had all these
angels and all these people in it that
nobody knew about and that angela is
actually the sister of thor and so
that's what angela's talking about when
she says like the angels of heaven were
able to reassemble this thing it's not
perfect it's not to its original state
but we did what we could and so there's
this really amazing moment because
remember thor and angela haven't always
seen eye to eye and there's always been
a bit of a conflict there between the
two of them but this is a massively
respectful thing that angela and the
angels of heaven have done here
something they didn't even really have
to do because they don't view odin the
same way that they view thor right they
see thor is somebody entirely different
and in a lot of ways far more honorable
than odin was and that's why angela says
like i told you i would clean up your
mess if i had to regardless of what that
mess happened to be so consider it
cleaned up and initially he's like i
know it's just a hammer like i know
that's that's it like it doesn't have
the power that it had before it's not
mjolnir as it's always been which is a
very important thing right it's not
milner the way that it's been before
which means that thor could use this and
in some situations it would be stronger
whereas in other situations it could be
weaker where it would have been stronger
so things aren't necessarily the same
it's really a way for marvel to kind of
rework the nature of the hammer and
under what conditions are the most
conducive to use it and so what ends up
happening here is thor's like i know
there's no power here but at the end of
the day you know it's i'm okay with that
and that's when angela says well i mean
maybe but honestly i think it just
depends on who wields it don't you and
so ultimately thor you know where he
turns around angela's gone and he's like
okay and then he actually prays to odin
and he says father i know somewhere you
can hear my prayer i am just so lost i
can't see the path that you've laid out
before me and then he hears this voice
that says keep your eyes open boy and
then it goes to the hammer and it says a
king cannot rule from his knees and so
in essence what it looks like here and i
could be wrong we won't know until we
get to the epilogue but what it looks
like here is the spirit of odin if you
can call it that odin without the odin
force i don't really know what that is
but the spirit of odin is now encased
inside the hammer whether that's true i
don't know but if if that is the case
this is a wholly different situation now
and no idea where in the world this even
goes i have no clue but having said that
i absolutely
love this god this is this was a
ridiculously good thor story i love it
when like writers come along and shift
things up change things around it keeps
it from growing stale right it keeps it
from getting boring right because after
a while i was like well here comes thor
with me on here
whatever but like i love that this is
being changed up i find it absolutely
awesome and refreshing so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end uh we'll probably make a full
story out of this don't worry thank you
all for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace